I have today for you maybe one of the
most brilliant pieces of political
satire and political interviewing that
I've seen Sasha Baron Cohen as we've
talked about has a new show on Showtime
it's called who is America Sacha Baron
Cohen you may know from characters such
as Ali G Borat Bruno the dictator he has
a new character who's an Israeli
anti-terrorism expert called Iran Murad
or as the Israelis might say Alan Mahad
and his Sacha Baron Cohen says during
during his his actual show and in this
interview he speaks to accused serial
child sex assault or Roy Moore who of
course lost to Doug Jones in the Alabama
special election accused by multiple
women including some very young women of
sexually assaulting them it's unclear
when this interview took place and
that's kind of relevant and the concept
is the following Colonel Allen Mahad
says to Roy Moore that they have
developed in Israel a device at piece of
technology which can detect sex
offenders and particularly pedophiles
because they secrete an enzyme called a
D DHT which is supposedly detectable by
this piece of equipment and what he does
is just as a sample he puts it over
himself and then he puts it over Roy
Moore and of course the the gag is it
beeps over Roy Moore Roy Moore doesn't
know that it's obviously just like a
metal detector it's totally standard
metal detector and it gets really really
awkward Roy Moore visibly uncomfortable
and ultimately ends the interview
earlier earlier than planned
take a look at this they have now used
this technology to identify other
abnormalities it turns out the sex
offenders and particularly pedophiles
secrete an enzyme for D DHT which is
actually detectable it is three times
the level of non perverts
so the phrase sweating like a rapist is
actually based on science
so in Israel they have developed a
machine that is used in schools and
playgrounds to detect anyone coming in
and if they detect a pedophile
the one alleged the law enforcement and
the schools within a hundred mile radius
it is very very simple to use you just
switch it on and because neither of us
or sex offenders then it make absolutely
nothing you just put it on you put it
nearby wait
it must be faulty it's malfunctioning
I'm sure it will do the same with the
other guy here ready
so is this silver jacket yes did you
lend the jacket to somebody else maybe
no I've been married for 33 so I never
had an accusation of such things I am
not accusing you I thought this is well
then if this is an instrument I did
certainly I'm not a pedophile okay no
but the machine is well I don't know
they may be Israeli technology hasn't
developed properly this is the 99.8%
world it is not saying that you are a
pedophile of course not I am simply
cutting this conversation right now
no thank you have you been nice I
support Israel I don't support this kind
of stuff thank you no it is I'm not
saying that you're a sex offender this
is just the best and we don't know when
it was filmed and that's sort of
relevant because of course Roy Moore was
accused by multiple people of child
sexual assault strictly speaking it's
not pedophilia because as far as we know
he didn't try to have sex with
prepubescent girls just girls that are
very young and not legally adults in
some states but the funniest part of all
this is that Roy Moore seemed to believe
the technology was legitimate right like
it's just a regular handheld metal
detector it clearly doesn't measure the
secretion of D DHT or any chemical which
would indicate whether somebody is a
pedophile as crazy as the entire thing
isn't as brilliant as the entire thing
is Roy Moore seem to believe that the
technology is real I actually think he
kind of passed the test though right
because if he said that oh this is
actually is not my suit coat it's
someone else I'm borrowing it yeah
then he would have failed right but I
think he found the best way out of this
open area that I think he said something
totally boneheaded which is I've been
married 33 years like that doesn't that
doesn't explain whether you do or don't
like little kids right if anything
that's a response that should raise a
red flag because it says nothing about
pedophilia right are you attracted to
prepubescent children
I've been married for 33 years it's
actually a non sequitur when you think
about I guess I'm also just comparing it
to the other Sacha Baron Cohen
interviews yeah like he got one
Republican to blurt out the n-word and
she expose himself he got other
Republicans to advocate for a
kindergardens program where this is very
for year olds have weapons yeah it's
much better no news yet about whether
Morris sending his Jewish lawyer who we
know he has because he and his wife
talked about how they have a Jewish
lawyer in order to prove that they don't
dislike Jews to sue the colonel here and
Sacha Baron Cohen of course dragging
these people beyond the limits of its
absurdity and I was thinking like how
far would he have to go where no one
like everybody gets that it's just just
a goof you know and I think it would be
disturbingly far I think it would be
crazy what he would have to do to get to
a point where nobody thinks it's a real
thing I mean there have been a few
people who have called him out
apparently he showed up to one gun store
yeah and the owner called him out for
being Borat and there's another
congressman who didn't advocate for the
program he was pushing so it doesn't
work every time if you don't like this
tell me why because I think that this is
absolutely and totally brilliant Donald
Trump has unleashed another unhinged
attack on Twitter a series of bizarre
and Confused tweets rife with the bogus
capitalization we've become accustomed
to and most importantly totally baseless
allegations the focus is Robert Muller
and Russia and the investigation I'm
going to show you the tweets it's very
clear Trump is nervous between the manna
for trial starting tomorrow Cohen ready
to give it all up to Robert Muller news
that Trump knew and approved of the
Trump Tower meeting with Russians
promising dirt on Hillary the guy is
clearly nervous and yesterday he
unleashed the following tirade about
Robert Muller I won't even mention that
there are 14 improper 13 improper
capitalizations here just just know that
they're there
there is no collusion Trump said the
Robert Muller rigged witch-hunt headed
but now by 17 increased from 13
including an Obama White House lawyer
angry Democrats was started by a
fraudulent dossier paid for by crooked
Hillary Hemu DNC therefore the
witch-hunt is an illegal scam is Robert
Muller ever going to release his
conflicts of interest with respect to
President Trump
including the fact that we had a very
nasty and contentious business
relationship I turned him down to head
the FBI one day before appointment a
special counsel and Comey is his close
friend also why is Muller only
appointing angry Dems some of whom have
worked for crooked Hillary others
including himself have worked for Obama
and why isn't Muller looking at all of
the criminal activity and real Russian
collusion on the Democrat side
Podesta dossier I'm wondering if there's
anything that's true in that rant 13
random capitalizations but beyond that
Democrats aren't running molars
investigation in fact Republican Moeller
appointed by Republican George W Bush is
running it the dossier wasn't fraudulent
it also wasn't the basis for the
investigation nothing about the probe is
illegal that's been explored
significantly in detail at this point
and the fact that Moeller was FBI
director for Obama again seems totally
irrelevant since he was appointed not
only is he a Republican he was appointed
by Republican George W Bush and what
you've got to realize is that Trump's
four tweet tirade does nothing to attack
the merit or the facts of what happened
or what Cohen knows or what Trump did
and I like how also Trump says he had a
very nasty relationship with Robert
Muller there's this story Pat that molar
angrily left Trump's golf club like ten
years ago over a dispute over golf club
fees Moeller has put out a statement or
his spokesperson has saying he just left
the club there was really no controversy
but in either case that just has nothing
to do with this seem so minor I'm moving
I'm going to a different club I don't
want to support this I'm gonna play golf
somewhere else
yeah that's why there's it there's a
so-called witch-hunt that has already
found 32 people to indict if that's the
big blockbuster that makes Muller
personally committed to it vendetta
against Trump you're gonna need to come
up with something bigger and this is all
the behavior somebody who's really
worried that the probe is not only not
ending its advancing and it's getting
closer and closer to Trump and to put a
final point on that let's go to White
House press secretary Sarah Huckabee
Sanders herself she said back in 2016
quote when you're attacking FBI agents
because you're under criminal
investigation you're losing that seems
to be the most prescient comment about
this entire thing and of course it
wasn't made about Trump at the time but
it certainly seems to apply today send
me your thoughts what do you think is
behind this absolutely unhinged Twitter
tirade that Trump Unleashed I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
Twitter at David
Hockman show we had a big bombshell
blockbuster story over the weekend and
it relates to that infamous Trump Tower
meeting this is the meeting attended by
Donald Trump jr. and Paul manna Ford and
Jared Kushner as well as ratata Italian
I'm sorry
Russian lawyer not Italian Russian
lawyer
Natalia vessel Matz kaya a twitch dirt
on Hillary was promised it's the center
of a lot of controversy and the big news
is that Michael Cohen now claims Donald
Trump's personal former personal lawyer
now claims that he was personally there
when Donald Trump was told about the
meeting ahead of time something he
previously denied knowing about and also
said let's do it and this if true is
absolutely and totally massive Michael
Cohen is reportedly willing and ready to
say this to special prosecutor Robert
Muller under oath and it has been
specifically and widely denied by Donald
Trump by everybody around him Donald
Trump claimed that he knew nothing about
this meeting until he heard about it the
following year when the New York Times
asked him about it before they reported
on it that would obviously be untrue if
Michael Cohen's allegations are true of
course Donald Trump continues to deny
knowing about it he says Cohen is lying
to get himself out of other trouble
Donald Donald Trump among other tweets
this weekend sent one where he said
quote I did not know of the meeting with
my son Don jr.
sounds to me like someone is trying to
make up stories in order to get himself
out of an unrelated jam taxi cabs maybe
he even retained Bill and crooked
Hillary's lawyer gee I wonder if they
helped him make the choice the problem
is Trump's already been caught lying
about this meeting right so aside from
Cohen's claim that Trump knew about the
meeting and approved the meeting Donald
Trump initially said he had nothing to
do with drafting the letter that was
published in response to news of the
meeting later we found out Trump
dictated the letter so if anybody here
has a history of lying about this
particular meeting its Donald Trump not
Michael Cohen and Trump said it multiple
lawyers said it's
Huckabee Sanders Trump jr. they all said
Trump knew nothing about it and there
have already been some hints that it
isn't so clear Trump knew nothing
because even though Rudy Giuliani now is
saying it's all lies back in May Rudy
Giuliani didn't even deny it he vaguely
sort of said I would be surprised if
Trump could remember knowing about the
meeting ahead of time which is very
different than to say no Trump knew
nothing about it and then just last
month Rudy Giuliani said the following
to George Stephanopoulos about who wrote
that letter responding to the meeting
which of course was riddled with lies
Rudy Giuliani now explaining why listen
everybody just changes their stories all
the time and a lot of people look at one
of the president shifting explanations
the White House shifting explanations
for what happened in that meeting at the
Trump Tower back in June of 2016 with
Don junior I remember when this was
first reported Jay Sekulow was on my
program so the president had nothing at
all to do with that letter later Sarah
sander said well wait he he sort of
weighed in but he didn't dictate it and
now this letter from the president's
lawyers say very very clearly he
dictated the statement how do you
explain those shifting he's like what
happened to me with the whole situation
of repaying the money that was laid out
by Cohen when I first when the first
president first talked about it nobody
focused on it nobody thought about it
that was a very busy time and then when
we got on board I went through
everything the only change we had to
make at that point this other change
that we made when you consider the big
scope of this narrative four or five
complicated thing the president was
there he was dealing with a letter at
first it was all denied and now you're
saying he dictator I don't know that Jay
Jay would have to answer that and I've
talked to him about it
I think Jay was wrong I mean this is the
reason you don't let the president
testify right you know every
recollection keeps changing this is the
best everyone's recollections are
constantly changing and Rudy Giuliani
tries to excuse the fact that Trump lied
by saying listen I also have lied on
television before of course not what
he's actually implying
so Giuliani has also been vague about
exactly what Trump knew and when and
then in March remember sam nunn Berg he
said to CNN that quote he talked about
it a week before meaning
talked about the meeting a week before
it happened and then we also have Steven
Bannon who in his own book said quote
the chance that Don Jr did not walk
these jou mows up to his father's office
on the 26th floor is zero meaning that
Trump jr. clearly talked about it with
Trump senior but you have to remember
that all along it always seemed like
Trump knew about it and was lying
because two days before the meeting the
meeting was on June 9 2016 2 days before
that June 7 2016 here is Trump on video
promising upcoming dirt on Hillary in
just a few days what a coincidence the
meeting was scheduled for the 9th and on
the 7th Trump says very soon in a few
days I'm gonna have news for you about
hillary clinton of course that never
happened because they didn't actually
get the dirt at the meeting but it's yet
another piece of the story that makes it
seem like Trump did know in fact there's
nothing to suggest Trump didn't know
we've got three people saying Trump
probably knew two Trump definitely knew
two days before Trump previewed it and
even on the day of there were some
tweets sent that related to it and he
dictated the response and also this was
a very small operation right his
presidential campaign yeah he's at his
own building the place where he lives in
the place where he works and it involved
his son his son-in-law and his campaign
manager how did he not know about he
knows nothing about what's why would he
know what's going on in his own building
involving his own kids his own campaign
and the person he's running against that
has nothing really a guy he was making a
deal for a window window treatments at
the time okay so legal issues possible
legal issues first of all no one is
claiming Cohen has recordings right so
it would be Michael Cohen's word that
Trump knew about it and Cohen is willing
to say that under oath to Robert Muller
but let's imagine it could be proven or
at least like if it rises to a claim
that Trump knew in advance and there was
a room full of people who said Trump
said let's do it and you
some kind of corroboration there's a
legal source quoted by Politico which
says everybody in the room when Trump
says let's do this is indictable if one
overt act occurred after the meeting
such as actually having the meeting at
Trump Tower that is potentially
accessory to conspiracy or a conspirator
number two Barbara McQuade is a former
US attorney she says if Trump was aware
of the meaning in advance and said let's
do it that he could face criminal
exposure under a number of different
legal theories although of course that's
separate from whether you can indict a
sitting president right the answer is
probably not you would first need to
impeach not gonna happen under a
Republican House and Senate and the big
issues gonna be corroboration because
Cohen's claim alone isn't likely to make
this open-and-shut but if you've got
Cohen's testimony under oath to robert
muller and Moeller can find emails or
texts that coincide with this that
people who were also in the room may
have sent or received then you have a
different story and Cohen Plus none
Berg's testimony and some text messages
now you've got a building story and this
isn't about whether Trump knew it seems
almost blindingly obvious that he did
the question is can you prove that Trump
knew and that's more complex slowly
every lie is falling apart you'd have to
be willingly ignorant or aggressively
stupid at this point to think Trump had
no idea about the meeting but the
question is can it be proven I think so
and I think it's part of a broader
strategy right Cohen puts out there that
Trump knew about the meeting and then he
has his lawyers go on TV and have them
deny it he denies himself on Twitter and
then you release the tapes I mean that
seems like a pretty good strategy to me
well along those lines
one other thing it's not a hundred
percent clear that the leak that Cohen
is willing to say this came from Cohen
because Cohen's lawyer Lanny Davis said
oh we didn't leak this and that suggests
it was the Trump team that leaked it why
would they do it historically they do
that to get ahead of something that's
even worse and of course Paul Manafort
trial starts tomorrow Michael Cohen is
about to say who knows what there's a
lot of different problems going on so if
Cohen was about to come forward with
this it's possible the Trump team leaked
it to get ahead of it and by the way I'd
still love to see the guys tax rate
let's not forget about that now I want
to go on to the next thing related to
Rudy Giuliani because I now have video
for you so bizarre and so confusing that
it's almost beyond belief except it's
the 2018 Trump administration and
everything is believable so the first
thing I talked about on the program
today
was Rudy Giuliani Trump's actual lawyer
moving from there was no collusion to
collusion wouldn't be a crime even if it
happened during some of these same
interviews he also started talking about
a second meeting related to the Russia
Trump Tower meeting okay I'm gonna try
to set this up in the clearest possible
way because it does start to get complex
I think by design he was interviewed on
CNN by Allison cammarata during that
interview Rudy Giuliani
admits to a previously unknown
pre-meeting to the Trump Tower meeting
with the Russians promising dirt on
Hillary and it's like we need a flow
chart Pat to explain the timeline of
this thing the Trump Tower Russia
meeting was on July I'm sorry June 9th
of 2016 June 7 of 2016 as I played for
you yesterday Donald Trump came out and
said very very soon I'm gonna have a
bunch of dirt on Hillary in this clip
what Rudy Giuliani admits to if you
listen carefully amidst all the
confusion that he seems to be
experiencing himself is that that same
day June 7 2016 there was a meeting held
to discuss the upcoming meeting with
Natalya vessel Mets kiyah
and the entire thing that we now know
about listen carefully to rule e
remember to Rudy we didn't know about
this meeting until Rudy mentioned it
yesterday on CNN the meeting with the
Russians that how can you be sure that
the president didn't know beforehand
you're saying it's just a he said my god
nobody can be sure of anything ok
situations like this you have two things
that argue against color it's two on one
I'm sorry three things then you get to
the other meeting he says he was sad
that the president wasn't at it's three
or four on one that's the two he also
was headed occult or Lanny Davis who
stated that there was a meeting two days
before
meeting took place with Donald Jr Jared
Manafort and two others gates and one
more person and that's a real meeting
you're saying that that that's a real
meeting on it on another provable
subject in which he would not
participate the meeting just so I've
been clear the meeting with the Russians
who was in there I have to Jared yeah it
was with Donald jr. yes Jared and to the
three other people I'm not sure of
exactly who and but the one who came in
or allegedly told the president about it
was Donald which Donal denies the
president denies and there's no
corroboration of and Cohen has never
said this at any time up until now okay
so Allison Cammarata says so that was a
real meeting and Rudy Giuliani says yeah
yeah that meeting took place he denies
that it was about the Trump Tower
meeting but of course just hours later
Donald Trump goes out and says hey in a
few days I'm gonna have really big big
stuff on Hillary
so of course Giuliani admits to this
other meeting having taken place
immediately it's huge people pick up on
it there was another meeting there was
another meeting apparently to talk about
allegedly to talk about the upcoming
Trump Tower meeting as you know that
same day Trump promises dirt on Hillary
so the timing of it is obvious but right
after this we hear the following from
Donald Trump just as a reminder from
yesterday that the timing it makes
perfect sense that there had just been a
meeting and Trump was coming from it and
then he says this next week and we're
gonna be discussing all of the things
that have taken place with the Clintons
I think you're gonna find it very
informative and very very
[Applause]
the alleged meeting that Rudy Guiliani
confirmed on CNN took place just hours
before Donald Trump came out and said
that so then of course this gets really
bad for Trump and Rudy Giuliani so
immediately Rudy Giuliani calls back in
to Fox News remember he had already been
on Fox and Friends in the morning he
calls back into Fox News and then he
denies anything about the second the
second meeting now there was no second
meeting it's almost impossible to
understand Giuliani in this clip but
what he is clearly doing is denying now
that the second meeting happened which
he just previously confirmed happened on
CNN earlier the same day there wasn't
another meeting that has been leaked but
hasn't been published yet that was a
meeting an alleged meeting three days
before
according to calling for according to
the leak maybe cold over the druthers I
don't know
they haven't pursued it and the two
publications they're not going to
publish it I think they found
independent contradiction he says there
was a meeting with Donald a junior with
Jared Kushner with Paul Manafort with
gates possibly two others in which they
out of the presence of the president
discussed the meeting with the Russian
we checked with their lawyers the ones
we could check with which was four of
the six that meeting
never ever took place didn't happen so
now he says it didn't happen after
saying just hours before in CNN that it
did everybody following so far so then
it was so confusing that there was a
follow-up question asked and Rudy
Giuliani making even less sense well I
let me just ask it this way so you've
told us about two meetings there was one
that the public knows about which when
you talk about a meeting and you say
that the president wasn't there that's
the one that everybody would assume that
we're all on the same page about but
what you're saying now is that there was
another meeting that was leaked that has
not been made public and I would assume
until now really described by you Rudy
Giuliani in detail that happened three
days prior that had Don jr. Jared
Kushner Paul manna for mates and
possibly two others and that's the
meeting that Michael Cohen says the
president was not or the president
knew about ahead of time but you say the
promote was not there no Cohen is not
alleging I don't look I don't know well
I have a to report is telling me Cohen
told them there was a meeting three days
before with the group of people that I
said and that they discussed the
committee and that the president was not
there he didn't say the president knew
about it okay I am Telling You that
meeting didn't take place never happened
yes there was another meeting which
didn't take place it's a meeting that
doesn't exist so so it's some sort of a
meeting it's a meet it's a non existent
meeting and then lastly here's a key
thing rudy giuliani choosing very
careful language Giuliani saying Trump
was not quote at the meeting which is
important and I'll explain after this is
Melissa Francis and I just want to jump
in I don't think any of that really
addresses the the question of why you
would say he wasn't at the meeting no
why are you saying that the president
wasn't at the meeting I understand those
two meetings that you just said out
there but that doesn't explain what
you're saying he was the mayor didn't
last if he was there no one asked to be
was there Cohen is alleging the meeting
took place we are making it clear that
the president was not at that meeting
Cohen doesn't even allege that cut it
off so Trump has a history of listening
to meetings via speakerphone so they
keep talking about how Trump wasn't
physically there he didn't have a
presence at the meeting he wasn't at
that meeting that to me is another one
of these signals that of course from
knew about it but he may even have been
connected via speakerphone but he wasn't
physically there I still am unsure this
is a strategy Pat right Giuliani could
be this dumb and this terrible of a
lawyer it could also be a way of
accidentally leaking things just to
cause confusion and to make it even more
difficult to know what the hell is going
on I really think he's this dumb though
and you know the Trump's best lawyers
are all now gone like Ty Cobb and John
Dowd and even Michael Cohen you think
this is really as well he's left with
the B team yeah Rudy Giuliani's the guy
who was loyal to him and he rewarded
them with a job if this isn't some
brilliant strategy who needs prosecutors
when you've got Rudy Giuliani as your
defense attorney that's all the
prosecuting that that you really need
send me your thoughts what do you think
is going on here with this
informational shell game I'm on Twitter
at D Pakman and the show is on twitter
at david pakman show welcome to the
David Pakman show
I am of course not David Pakman I am
Benjamin Dixon host of the podcast the
Benjamin Dixon show you could find me
anywhere you find podcast David is out
of town and he will be back tomorrow and
in the meantime we have a lot of news to
cover of course we have to begin the day
with the President of the United States
Donald Trump who has once again inserted
himself into the legal process
surrounding the Mullah probe I want to
bring up a tweet that the president
shared early this morning and this is
what he had to say he said this is a
terrible situation and Anthony attorney
general Jeff Sessions should stop this
rigged witch-hunt right now before it
continues to stay in our country any
further Bob Muller is totally conflicted
and his 17 angry Democrats that are
doing his dirty work are a disgrace to
the United States that's how he started
he continued with the next tweet this is
what he had to say he said Paul Manafort
worked for Ronald Reagan Bob Dole and
many other highly prominent and
respected political leaders he worked
for me for a very short time why didn't
the government tell me that he was under
investigation these old charges have
nothing to do with collusion a hoax all
right we'll stop right there with those
two tweets so the president has already
you know he's done this before
he's inserted himself into the process
but this is the first time that he's
directly called
for Attorney General Jeff Sessions to
put it into this you will recall last
week in the week before that Republicans
started the process of impeaching Rod
Rosenstein because of this investigation
and the president is getting nervous if
you if you see his behavior patterns if
you see what he's doing he's making the
mistakes and it bear it's very likely
that he is going to implicate himself
with his actions at this point it's the
same you know the saying that it's not
the crime that gets you it's the
cover-up and that's what the president
is doing here
now he's of course labeling it in
witch-hunt that's what he does he labels
everything a hoax anything that he
disagrees with it's considered a hoax
but this is like I said before this is
the first time that he is outright
called
for Jeff Sessions to put it into this
thankfully Jeff Sessions doesn't have
the ability to put an end to this
because he has recused himself from this
process but underneath all of this is
what the president is actually trying to
do he's trying to win this in the court
of public opinion he knows that if he
can make this issue as hyper partisan as
possible then it's very likely that
nothing will be done even if Muller
turns up something sensitive something
that implicates him now as it stands
right now there's not a lot of evidence
that we've been privy to publicly that
implicates the president directly I
think the closest thing we have now is
Donald Trump jr. where it's come out
that the president knew about the the
meeting with Russian operatives at the
Trump Tower previously Trump jr. told
the Congress that the President did not
know about it and so the highest level
of ramifications so far really rests
with Donald Trump jr. and the
possibility of perjury but that still
hasn't stopped the President of the
United States from being bold enough and
brash enough to insert himself in the
process in a very direct fashion this
unless you know that we're way past we
were so far beyond any standardized
norms any sense of protocol any any
concern for the appearance of letting
justice carry its carry its way out you
know we're well past that point at this
point it's a free-for-all and the
president has decided to wage his war
against Bob Muller and the Department of
Justice his Department of Justice and
before I even finish that sentence we
have to point this out right the irony
the the biggest irony in all of this is
that this is Bob Muller who was a
Republican rod Rosen Stein who was a
Republican or at least was appointed by
Republicans you have a Republican
Department of Justice headed up by a
Republican Attorney General who was
appointed by a Republican president and
they are waging a war against their own
but they're swearing that this is all a
result of the Democratic Party I want to
bring up the last tweet from Donald
Trump this morning on the issue he said
Russian collusion with the Trump
campaign one of the most successful in
history is a total hoax the Democrats
paid for the phony and discredited
dossier which is which was alone would
call me McCabe's strokes and
and his lover hit the lovely Lisa Paige
used to begin the witch-hunt disgraceful
disgraceful it's a little difficult
reading the President of the United
States because of the absurd things that
he says but but the fact of the matter
is that he's still spreading himself
fake news the dossier the origins of the
dossier goes back to a Republican
operative that was trying to do research
on opposition research on Donald Trump
that's been proven but that doesn't stop
the President of the United States from
spreading his own fake news from from
doing everything that he can to muddy
the waters because he knows this thing
to be true he knows that people who love
Him and still support him no matter what
he's done so far they don't care about
the truth they don't care that the
dossier actually had origins in the
Republican Party they are going to
continue to say the same lie that it
started with with Hillary Clinton and
started with Democrats if they're gonna
continue to push that because the
President of the United States continues
to push that same life so here we are
with which stories that in any other
administration would be enough to bring
that administration to a complete
gridlock but this is the unique strength
of Donald Trump this is a unique ability
his uncanny gift if he's talented in
anything it's not being a businessman
it's not being a leader
it's his his unfettered shamelessness
his ability to go further and further
and further to destroy any sense of
shame that this country has and we are
not even in a position to actually
process this we're dealing with the
president who throws so many different
ridiculous situations in at us in a
single news cycle that we can't even
really adjust to to consider how
significant what just happened really is
I mean there's there have been new
cycles where in one day we have five
stories that in any other administration
would have brought that administration
down but for Donald Trump it's just the
12 o'clock news break and that's his
uncanny gift and this is why when
everyone was saying I don't know if you
recall earlier in the administration
people kept tweeting and kept saying
this can't be the new normal this isn't
the new normal the reality of it is is
that
is the new normal because we have all
gotten adjusted to it we've all gotten
accustomed to the President of the
United States being involved in any
number of scandals that would have
brought down any administration I don't
care democrat or republican what the
President of the United States is mired
in right now is enough was enough to
bring down any previous administration
and yet he just keeps trudging through
his own swamp that he's supposed to be
emptying out it's getting to be time for
all media across party lines across
platforms to unite to protect themselves
from Donald Trump who is waging a
never-ending increasingly disturbing war
on the media I told you last week that
the Trump administration has launched
some major attacks on freedom of the
press calling the media the enemy of the
American people talking about journalism
licenses opening up libel laws to make
it easier to sue media outlets they
banned CNN reporter Caitlin Collins from
a Rose Garden press conference for some
questions she had asked they've been
pushing this outrageously partial push
poll to turn people even more strongly
against the media and now Donald Trump
went on it this isn't even the first
Sunday Twitter tirade that we're talking
about today but he went on a Sunday
Twitter tirade against what he calls the
very unpatriotic media why is the media
unpatriotic according to Trump because
they report what government does he
specifically calls out the New York
Times and The Washington Post who by the
way have done really great investigative
reporting on the Trump administration
this is what dictators do directly
attacking the press that holds them
accountable or at least tries to hold
them accountable and Donald Trump
tweeting when the media driven insane by
their Trump derangement syndrome reveals
internal deliberations of our government
it truly puts the lives of many not just
journalists at risk very unpatriotic
Freema freedom of the press also comes
with a responsibility to report the news
accurately 90% of media coverage of my
administration is negative despite the
tremendously positive results we are
achieving it's no surprise that
confidence in the media is at an
all-time low I will not allow our great
country to be sold out by anti Trump
haters in the dying newspaper industry
no matter how much they try to distract
and cover it up our country is making
progress under my leadership and I will
never stop fighting for the American
people as an example the failing New
York Times and the Amazon Washington
Post do nothing but write bad stories
even on positive achievements they will
never change it's quite a mouthful
90% actually sounds low like I can think
of three to four things Trump has done
that makes sense and some of those might
even have been done by accident if 10%
of coverage of Trump were positive it
would actually be too high
given what Donald Trump is actually done
because this is an administration that's
a total and utter sham and what he's
trying to do is something that's not
that uncommon for the right which is
they want to get a monopoly on
patriotism it's another sign of
authoritarianism being the arbiters the
gatekeepers of what's patriotic and
what's not patriotic and it was also
revealed yesterday interestingly the
Donald Trump had a meeting with the New
York Times publisher AG salts burger and
talked about how he thinks the media is
the enemy of the people and sults burger
reportedly warned Trump and said you
know it's kind of a dangerous thing for
you to be doing that and yes it's
dangerous to the foundational tenets of
our country PR wise I don't know that
it's that dangerous for Trump to call
the media the enemy of the American
people because he's having some success
turning his base against a Free Press
yeah it is really working for him and
that's why fewer and fewer Americans
support like the Robert Moeller
investigation him his poll numbers are
going up to I just think it's completely
unfounded like it's not the media's job
to be patriotic it's the media's job to
tell the truth and to be objective and
you know they were gonna be patriotic we
would have state-run media which that's
another point which is layer one is if
you're going to attribute patriotism to
the media I argue that discussing and
exposing what our government does is a
patriotic act right because it aligns
with what the sort of foundational
tenets of our country are but there's
another side to it which is media should
not be making decisions on the basis of
patriotism they should be making
decisions on the basis of their duty to
report what it is that's going on and
and it's almost like irrelevant whether
we attribute patriotism to the media
yeah I mean you'd see that maybe in
North Korea or Russia are but hopefully
not in the United States the most
triada kacct you can do as a media
outlet is to report on what is happening
and what the government does is part of
that and of course Trump claimed to be a
fan of transparency during the campaign
seems almost hypocritical that now he
thinks reporting on what the government
does is bad but that being said as I
mentioned earlier Paul Manafort trial
starts tomorrow it's very clear Michael
Cohen is about to give up the really
good goods Trump's own CFO from the
Trump Organization might be called to
testify under oath the guys probably
panicking and that relates to why he's
going on multiple totally outrageous
hyperbolic apoplectic Twitter rants on
Sunday over the weekend